[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL: Hi, everybody.
My name is Paul Saxman.
And welcome to this week's
Google Maps Developers Live.
With me today is visualization
expert Brendan--
Google Maps visualization
expert Brendan Kenny.
And today we're going to
go over a series of
visualizations we did just last
week, actually, with the
Google Maps API.
Show you how the process works,
show you a little bit
of the code, about how we built
these visualizations and
just go from there.
So that the visualizations
include things like heat maps,
symbols, and then we're going to
talk again about Brendan's
CanvasLayer API, which is
kind of the ultimate
visualization API.
Before we dive into that,
though, a couple of quick
announcements.
If I go over to the Google
Developers blog here.
Two things that we announced
this week.
One is that the Google Places
API Developer challenge.
We've extended the deadline
for submissions.
A lot of developers were asking
for a little bit more
time, so we were happy
to oblige.
Submissions aren't due until
the end of November.
So.
November--
I believe it's November--
How many days in November?
30, 31st.
BRENDAN: 30?
PAUL: Something like that.
The other thing that we
announced recently is two new
APIs for Enterprise users.
One is the Google Maps
geolocation API, which
Enterprise users can use to get
geolocation without using
GPS coordinates.
So it's based on Wi-Fi
and cellular towers.
And the other one is the
Google Maps Tracks API.
It allows Enterprise developers
to actually store
geolocation information.
Store and actually display
And analyze that
data on a map.
So it includes a nice feature,
a geofencing feature, which a
lot of Enterprise customers
really want.
So with that, I'm going to
hand it off to Brendan.
Brendan is going to talk about
this wonderful data set that
we worked with and kick off
some visualizations.
check.
BRENDAN: Sure.
So we're looking for an example
that we could just
have a bunch of different ways
that we could look at.
A particular data set, a single
data set, and just some
of the different ways that
we can use the Maps API
specifically, and some of the
new visualization features
that we introduced over the
summer to explore all the
different facets of this data.
And we happened to come across
this really great data set.
We can take a look at the
website here for the
Climatological Database for
the World's Oceans.
And I think it has a French
name that is abbreviated
there, that I actually don't
know what it is.
And as you can see it's
an awesome website.
And an EU grant paid for this
group of universities, and I
think a few other institutions
to actually go back and look
at ship logs from 1750
to 1854, and
actually digitize them.
So that you get things like
latitude and longitude for
particular dates.
And then they actually
included weather
information as well.
For the beginning they included
wind speed and direction.
And then they also as time
went on and technology
improved, for instance, getting
reliable thermometers,
they actually started including
temperature
information.
And the reason they were doing
this is so that they could
push back data for their climate
models or for climate
models back centuries, because,
while there was
land-based readings at that
time that we still have
records for, there was no
actually digitized records for
the oceans, which is obviously
a huge feedback
loop for the climate.
And so they actually went
in and they did
a really good job.
And it's actually quite
impressive how
much work they did.
You can see some examples
here of the kind of
beautiful logs here.
But you can imagine that OCR
is not going to work for
digitizing these things.
And so they actually had people
go back and digitize
all these things, and make
sure that the values were
reasonable, and they converted
all the different windscales
that were used by several
different
countries at the time.
And they ended up converting--
they got about 250,000--
245,000 data points for latitude
and longitude, the
date, and the wind speed
and direction at least.
And a couple of extra
data points.
PAUL: And also some narrative
information as well.
BRENDAN: Beyond it, yeah.
So they got some great narrative
information about
things like a pleasant
breeze this evening.
Things like that.
PAUL: Which we haven't started
analyzing yet.
BRENDAN: Yeah, we have--
PAUL: It's on our to-do list.
BRENDAN: We were talking
about a--
What's it called?
The--
PAUL: Oh, sentiment analysis?
BRENDAN: There you go.
Yeah.
PAUL: Oh, we'll go and
[INAUDIBLE] about the data.
So you said there's 250,000
data points?
And how many countries?
BRENDAN: So there's eight
different countries.
And it's not all
evenly spread.
So they digitized a huge number
of Spanish log books,
and log books from the UK.
Was it the UK already by 1750?
I don't know.
Anyway--
PAUL: That's a good question.
BRENDAN: So and then there's,
on the other side of the
scale, there's 51 data
points for the US.
There's like one voyage where
they came to Europe, I think,
and then came back.
And so it's unevenly spread,
and then over time it's
unevenly spread as well.
So some years will have a few
hundred and some years will
have up to about 8,000
data points.
So that actually makes for a
good challenge in terms of
trying to find good ways of
visualizing across that larger
range of interesting
data points.
Do we actually have the
data somewhere?
PAUL: Ah, open up Data
and then Sample Data.
Oh, actually no.
The entire data set
[INAUDIBLE]
BRENDAN: OK.
Yeah.
BRENDAN: [INAUDIBLE] today.
BRENDAN: So, it's
kind of this--
it's almost this comma separated
value, CSV, file
format but not quite.
And so it's kind of a pain to
get into a certain format, but
it ends up not being
that hard.
You take column A, column
B and add them together.
And you get the date.
And that sort of thing.
You have to normalize across
some of the ways they store
like tenths of a degree
and things like that.
But in the end, we actually
started with a data format
just that would be extremely
easy to put on screen and be
able to see if we've done
something very wrong, or if
their data seems reasonable.
And our goal at first was just
to see what we have.
And so we wanted to put
something on screen as quickly
as possible.
And so we made this first format
you can see up here at
the top, which was just
we sorted by year.
And then we took a
list of all the
coordinates of all the ships.
We weren't doing any kind of
individual ship tracking at
this point.
And just put latitude and
longitude in these giant
arrays of points associated
with the year.
And with that we then went over,
and we actually used the
new heat map library, which is
part of the visualization
library of the Maps API.
And just so we could put on
screen and see as quickly as
possible-- oh yeah,
it's right here--
what it looks like.
And so this is what we
ended up getting.
We have here the world,
obviously.
And spread out over the world
you can see all the different
data points just drawn extremely
quickly to see where
things are.
And you can actually
get a nice sense--
well we can zoom out a step here
--and you can get a sense
of density.
So you can see, where you
especially have traffic.
And, obviously, you can see
already that people stay
really close to the Cape of Good
Hope because of the winds
and currents down there.
Whereas they are much more
spread out over the North
Atlantic due to the different
countries that leave the
Atlantic here.
PAUL: And you see a couple of
interesting things too.
You can assume that the origin
or the destination of most of
these voyages was Europe because
of where the data
centered around.
But then also you can
see the major
trading hubs in the East.
BRENDAN: Right.
PAUL: You have, I think,
Singapore is in there.
You got to go over there.
Maybe Indonesia, Singapore.
BRENDAN: Up into India.
PAUL: Yeah, India as well.
So you see--
BRENDAN: There's no
Suez Canal yet.
PAUL: Yeah.
BRENDAN: And then so there's
actually a text box down here,
where we can actually
change the year.
So if we want to see 1756, 1757,
and you can definitely
see traffic increase.
And you can see that all of a
sudden now we have quite a few
more destinations in
South America.
And you actually see
it increase.
If we picked 1780s we can
see a bigger spread.
We even have something off here
off the west coast of the
United States.
And, then down here,
all the way down to
Chile, or, well, almost.
So that gave us a good start.
And the heat maps are great.
This is something that's
literally-- we actually can
take a look here.
So first, to load
the heat maps.
So, we don't want to bloat the
main maps API library.
A lot of people don't make a map
and put a heat map on it.
So we wanted to make it
an optional download.
So you can see here on the URL
you actually add an additional
parameter, libraries equals
visualization.
And this tells the maps API to
also load the code for the
visualization library.
And at that point you get
some additional classes
available to you.
And in this case, we're going
to use a new heat map.
And so here is actually
the constructor call
for the heat map.
You just say new heat
map layer and
pass it data parameter.
And in that you pass it
an array of lat longs.
And so in this case, we actually
have just this heat
map, and we select on 1750.
The only slight tricky thing
here is we had to convert to
actually explicitly the
lat long objects.
But other than that it's
really dead simple.
This is the entirety
of the code.
Half of this code is just
the year selection
text box at the bottom.
So that's the great thing about
the heat map libraries.
You just drop it in and
instantly get a picture, and
get a great sense of where your
data is, what it's doing.
But there are issues.
So first of all, you can see the
colors blend in with the
blue, because we're in the
oceans as opposed to the land.
They're very typical heat map
colors, so you can actually
get a sense of pulling it
up to the red intensity.
But it doesn't necessarily
stand out.
And the other thing is
this the idea of
dissipation of points.
So here, at this zoom level, you
can still get a sense of
continuity between points
in the logbook.
So usually they are
about a day apart.
But when ships are really going
quickly, you can see
that they start to spread out.
Now, this becomes a bigger
problem as you zoom in,
because heat maps are a
measure of density.
As you zoom in, you have more
space and fewer points per
unit of space.
And so you actually have the
points spread out more and
more until you get to the point
you can no longer tell
continuity between points.
This is expected, because
heat maps, I said,
are measures of density.
This is expected.
But it's not necessarily the
optimal way of displaying the
data that you necessarily
want.
And so there's a bunch of things
that we can actually
tweak here.
There's a bunch of knobs and
levers that we can use to make
a heat map our own, and make it
very specific to our data.
And Paul is going to walk
us through that.
PAUL: OK.
Absolutely.
Yeah, so from here, we recognize
these, may not
necessarily issues of the
visualization, but ways that
we want to go and tweak it.
Make it more informative
to the user.
So, first thing we did--
so going back to our heat maps
--is, so we actually
simplified the map itself.
So a few things we did
here is we went into
terrain mode, for example.
So we felt that the actual, the
roadmap wasn't the most
valuable way to see the map just
because at that time most
of these roads didn't exist.
And we were more, primarily,
focused on the countries,
which is the information
that we wanted to see.
So the other thing is actually,
if you notice, for
example, on the left-hand side
here we, actually, remove most
of the controls.
So the only real control we
wanted was a zoom control, and
then this control down
at the bottom.
And this one's a
little bit new.
I'll explain in a second.
The control on the bottom is
actually a slider that we put
in, or a range input box.
So the couple other things that
we did too to this, so we
simplified the map, we
simplified the controls, and
we actually tweaked the
heat map a little bit.
So you can see here is one thing
is that we turned off
dissipation.
So as we zoom in, the heat map
no longer dissipates, as the
points get more spread out.
And it's a nice feature here,
because what we really wanted
to see is these tracks,
these voyages.
And this allows us
to retain that
information at any zoom level.
BRENDAN: It's a tradeoff,
right?
So as you zoom in, the heat map
spread gets quite large
relative to what you
see on the screen.
So that doesn't necessarily
represent the ship.
But on the other hand, you
actually get continuity
between zoom levels.
And so it really depends on
the data that you have.
If you know very precisely
every single point.
If you're interested in points
as opposed to tracks, then you
might not want to
use dissipation.
PAUL: Yeah, exactly.
So, for example, to emphasize
this point.
I can't necessarily say exactly
what port or what city
this boat was in when they were
actually taking examples.
I can assume there were in
Dakar, but not necessarily.
But if we had dissipation on,
things would actually align
better with the map.
Maybe a nice feature to have
a toggle for that.
So in terms of the control, we
notice that a lot of these
voyages actually spent multiple
years, because they
were sailing or steam ships.
So we wanted to give these a way
to actually visualize the
data over time.
So this is something we did with
this custom control on
the bottom.
So it's just an input
range box.
What we do is every time as it
slides to the right or to the
left, we actually pick a
different date range and
display it on the map.
And this shows how quickly
these heat maps can be
rendered, because each of
these is being rendered
dynamically as the slider
is being moved.
It's not exactly real time.
If I grab it and try to slide
it all the way to the right,
there's a little bit
of lag, but it is
actually pretty good.
And this is on a relatively
new hardware.
So, also keep that in mind if
you're building one of these.
You should make sure it works
with older hardware.
So if we go to the code.
So this is heat map one.
So, here we see a couple of
things that we pointed out.
So, again, the code
is fairly simple.
Disable all the default
UI controls,
add in the zoom control.
I'm a bit of a minimalist,
I like to actually remove
everything, and then
add back only what
I need to my interface.
And down here you can see with
the heat map I actually set
the dissipation off.
And this is something that-- we
didn't mention our radius.
So radius you can actually
control how far each point
actually spreads out on the map
at default zoom levels.
So here we're saying a
radius of two pixels.
Everything else--
one other thing.
This is actually in
the previous one.
Instead of actually having these
map controls actually
outside of the map in HTML
down structure, we can
actually use the Maps
API to actually put
it in the map itself.
So you can see here this DIV
with the sliders actually down
here in the DOM tree.
It is actually below the
map in the DOM tree.
But here by calling Map and then
adding the controls, we
can actually push it into
the map itself.
So from there, we thought
this is a pretty nice
visualization.
I think we were seeing
a lot more.
So the next step that we took
though is to tweak the
visualization a little
bit more.
So, again, I mentioned
we can see these
actually multi-year voyages.
So we wanted to emphasize or
give the user the ability to
see these a little bit better.
So here I allow the user to
actually set a year range.
So there's a maximum
of 10 years.
Here you can see that the
visualization actually updates
a little bit more slowly as
I scroll to the right.
And that's because we're dealing
with a pretty massive
number of data points.
I think at this point we're
probably rendering somewhere--
so it's 10 years, there's
a hundred years total.
20,000 plus or minus
data points.
But since we can expand this
out over 10 years, we can
actually see these multi-year
voyages forming up in the
Pacific for example.
And actually we see a lot more
and get a stronger sense of
density in the Atlantic
in terms of where
the ships were going.
And this is a really interesting
area here.
BRENDAN: And you get much
prettier little gradients,
like around Northern
Africa there.
PAUL: Yeah.
The data really pops out more.
And I think this is really
interesting 1776-1786, you can
see a lot more activity down
in Brazil and Argentina.
So, and again, I think this data
was hosted by a research
group in Spain.
And so I don't know if that
necessarily affected where
they were actually
sampling from.
So, we really like that, but one
thing that Brendan pointed
out earlier is that the this
blue one, or the green to red
heat map, which is a really
default, pretty much standard
style for heat maps, I
didn't really show
very well on water.
So if we had like really sparse
samples, and those
didn't stick out as much.
So the idea was to tweak the
heat map to make it more
prominent on the map.
And we did that by actually
specifying a custom gradient
for the heat map.
So here you can see, if we
scroll forward a few years.
I think it was in the
mid to late 1700s.
Now we can see these voyages
that as actually probably a
single ship in kind of the
Pacific, this data actually
sticks out relatively well
on the blue background.
We take a peek at the code.
So that's the slider.
So setting up a gradient is
really as simple as specifying
RGB values.
So you specify any number of
these as far as I can tell.
And one trick with this is make
sure that the first one
actually has alpha value of
zero, so it's completely
transparent.
Otherwise, that's actually the
default color that's overlaid
on top of the map.
And then from there, I think,
I did yellow, orange, red.
Oh no, it was actually
the other way around.
It was red, orange,
white gradient.
So kind of fiery looking.
A couple of other things I
did to the heat map here.
So in addition to specifying
the gradient, I
specified an opacity.
I think default opacity
is about 0.6.
I actually made it more opaque
to actually make the data look
more prominent.
And I set this max intensity.
I don't understand, so how does
max intensity work with
the heat maps?
BRENDAN: So, that's the ceiling
value that everything
gets normalized to.
So, normally, it would
[INAUDIBLE]
if you got 18 points on top of
each other, that would be
assigned to the max value of the
heat map, and everything
else would get normalized
and brought down.
So like nine points on top of
each other somewhere else
would only have half
of the intensity.
So max intensity sets a limit.
So 18 gets floored, or
clamped down to 10.
And that nine is now 9/10 of
intensity instead of half.
PAUL: Interesting.
BRENDAN: So it's a way of making
sure that we have a
couple points when the ships
are in ports, and they have
many times more points there
than they do other places,
because they're there
for a couple weeks.
And those can drown out
all the other data.
The other data turns to the
lowest level, and you
lose all that data.
So, we're less interested in the
ports for visualization.
We want to see all the points.
So you've set that
max intensity.
PAUL: So, essentially, a high
pass filter, so we're
filtering out the high
sample rate.
BRENDAN: Yeah, I guess
you can say that.
PAUL: Cool.
So, another, again, it's just a
matter of a few tweaks that
we put in the code.
So opacity, gradient,
and max intensity.
And we can get a really nice
effect on our map.
So we're going to go to
one more heat map.
And then, actually, we might
call it a day with
one more heat map.
Actually, two more heat maps.
Oh, I didn't want to
do this one yet.
This one's a lot of fun.
Two more heat maps.
So, in addition to adjusting the
heat map itself, you have
the ability to actually
style the map as well.
Well beyond what I showed before
with just changing the
controls, and changing
the terrain mode.
Again, like I said earlier, we
really wanted to focus on the
countries, and the data.
So, what I did here is
using the styled map.
The styled map, a feature
of the Google Maps API.
I took everything, basically
toned the map down to just
show the land masses
and the countries.
And, then, on top of that
I put the really
intense heat map.
And this allows us, looking at
this data here, this allows us
to pretty much see everything
that's going on.
Even though it's like a single
voyage in the Pacific, we can
see that actually that data
pops or sticks out really
nicely on this map.
So the styled map API.
If we go check, take a look
at that real quick.
So, here I'm actually
specifying the
style for the map.
And again, the way I personally
like to build
visualizations, I like turn
everything off, and then only
add in the stuff that
I really want.
So, here you see I've actually
set that everything on the map
is made invisible.
And I sequentially add back the
information that I want.
So here I've specified that
I want to show the water,
basically color zero.
I want to show the
water labels.
And here I actually have to
set the stroke and fill.
So that's the color of the
text and what actually
surrounds the text.
So the idea is that if you have
white text and a black
background, you probably want
to do some kind of a stroke
around it to make it
blend in with the
background a little bit.
Kind of a minor tweak.
If you play around with this,
you can see what it looks like
without that.
And, again, I turned
the landscape on.
And I turned the countries on.
So in here I didn't have to do
stroke and fill on the labels,
because it's, I think, white
text on a gray background.
Oh and inverted lightedness.
Actually that's the
trick here.
Is that if I inverted
lightedness on the water
labels, I got a blue text
on a white background.
Or blue text with
a white stroke.
And here, by default,
the country labels
are white on black.
So I just inverted
that around.
So that's actually specifying
the style.
And you actually just set
that on your map with a
single line of code.
So this may look a
little daunting,
setting up these styles.
But what we did when we actually
launched the Styled
Maps, is we created this thing
called Styled Maps Wizard.
Basically, this tool allows you
to tweak all the different
settings that I showed
a moment ago
in a graphical interface.
And, once you've actually
tweaked it, you can get
actually the JSON,
or the JavaScript
object information out.
So that you can drop
that into your map.
So, for example, let's
reset this.
I can say all.
I turn the visibility to off.
And I get a blank map.
And now I want to say, for
example, I could turn the
water, turn the visibility back
on, and now I get the
water on my map.
I can specify and do
a custom color.
Really quickly you can create
a nice visualization using
this tool, or a nice
Styled Map.
And then, when you're done,
you just hit the Show JSON
button here, and you get all
the code you need for your
Styled Map.
With that, I'm going
to pass it.
We were going to give
a demo of symbols.
We're running a little over on
time, but definitely want to
show what Brendan did with the
CanvasLayer, because the
CanvasLayer is really the
ultimate tool for building
these visualizations.
Heat maps and symbols are great
for getting your data on
the map relatively quickly.
CanvasLayer, since it uses HTML5
and WebGL the world's
your oyster at that point.
BRENDAN: Right.
Well, it's a tradeoff because,
suddenly, instead of having a
bunch of helpful libraries
that help you do what you
want, and have a bunch of
options to tweak, you
basically have to do everything
yourself.
So, you have a ton of
flexibility and a ton of
performance available, but you
now have to every single pixel
that you want on the screen,
you're going to have to make
sure it is drawn yourself.
There's no real infrastructure
yet.
We're slowly building that up.
Then there's a bunch of other
libraries that you can bring
in to do this, but--
PAUL: Oh, a quick one
with that too.
BRENDAN: You do have
to do it yourself.
PAUL: Browser compatibility.
BRENDAN: Yes, so browser
compatibility is something
that you need to worry about.
It's not everywhere yet, but it
is supported in Firefox and
Chrome for a while now.
It's supported in Opera
on Windows.
But I don't think Opera
on the Mac has it yet.
And then it's in Safari, but
your user actually has to go
to the develop menu and turn
on WebGL themselves.
It's not on by default.
You have to look at your
analytics for your website.
You have to think about your
users and the kind of audience
you want to attract.
And say, is this something
that I want to support?
It brings me awesome things, but
it might cut out some of
my audience, is my audience is
the kind of audience that you
can say, well, would you mind
if you're using Internet
Explorer switch just
to use this.
Or you're going to lose them.
So it's not worth it.
The other option is you can use
some cool WebGL thing and
then just have a fall back
for Internet Explorer.
It's a really easy check
to see if WebGL is
supported on a browser.
And if it's not, then you could
do something that, like
these heat maps, or some
other kind of generate
tiles sort of thing.
As a fall back.
So at least they can get a sense
of the data that you're
visualizing.
If not the full kind of
WebGL experience.
So for CanvasLayer, for this
example, we just wanted to
throw together something really
quickly to see as kind
of an experiment how quickly we
could get something up and
running, and actually usable.
So what we decided to do was
look at actually the wind data
that was associated
with these ships.
So at each data point the ships
actually recorded wind
direction and the speed
of that wind there.
And so what we wanted
to see was first
just how that looked.
So we have here-- and it should
load in a second.
There it is.
Kind of hard to see,
but it's there.
So what we have here
is our ship tracks.
And what we're doing actually
is we have a ship position,
and we're actually looking three
days into the future,
and three days behind.
This window in time to see what
was wind like around this
point in space and time.
And so with the idea that over
a few days the wind is
probably at least somewhat
consistent, especially ocean,
when you're much more dominated
by the trade winds
than the local weather.
And so, it turns out,
it actually is.
You get some really nice
coherency with the wind
information.
You can see actually here.
So here's a ship traveling
south west.
Southwest, there you go.
And you can see the actual wind
direction that actually
looks like it's propelling
them really well.
And you can see the same
thing over here.
And so now we can actually
scroll through time, and see
as these ships travel.
The problem is we have
100 years that
scrolls quite quickly.
But you can see, as these ships
travel, the wind vectors
fade in and fade back out.
And the nice thing about
WebGL here is that
it can handle all--
I've actually loaded all 250,000
data points at once,
and just said, give me
this window of time.
And so here you can see actually
a whole fleet of
ships leaving, and just get a
sense of the wind that they're
encountering.
And here you can
see that things
are a lot more confused.
And actually, we're not sure
yet exactly what's that's
caused by, ocean currents, or
being so close to land, or
maybe it's just some captains
are better at actually
measuring wind speed
than others.
That sort of thing.
So we're still looking
at that data.
So that's pretty interesting.
And it's definitely cool to
see these ship patterns as
they travel through time.
But it didn't really
show off WebGL.
Well, you can tell it's
extremely smooth.
And it's actually much smoother
than you get, because
we were actually animating up to
a few thousands data points
on screen at once, and
it has no problem
shifting through there.
It doesn't visually give us the
sense that we really have
a lot of power at
our fingertips.
You also don't get a sense
of what's going on the
ocean at that spot.
You have a sense of maybe what
are the wind, the shipping
[INAUDIBLE] that day, which is
literally what the date is.
But you don't get a sense
of what's going on.
So, actually, if you go back
to the original data, the
report they did when
they finished.
They actually were using
it for climate models.
And what they did was they said,
so if we assume that
wind patterns, typically
have seasonal pattern.
So in the winter winds typically
do this, in the
summer winds typically
do this.
What if we actually looked
at all the data for
the winter at once?
All the data for the
summer at once?
So we did that.
Except we looked at a
much finer scale.
We said, so what if we looked
at all the first weeks of
January at once?
So all 104 years of data brought
in into the same
screen at once.
And then you can scroll through
a whole year in the
same way, but actually
have all 104 years on
the screen at once.
And so that's what this
visualization is.
So we actually can see now,
this is all years,
overlayed at once.
And we're scrolling through.
So we're here, now we're in
February, and then into March,
and April, and May.
And finally into the summer.
So you can see, at this level
it's much more noisy.
But you can already start
to see certain patterns.
So let's see if we can
find a good spot.
So, already you can see the
typical treatments you
actually take straight
to the Americas.
And these are the ones
that Columbus rode.
Actually you can see, right
down here you can see this
giant swoop here.
And you can see really great
patterns here, where it seems
like all these ships were
actually in quite good
agreement about what
was going on in the
middle of the Atlantic.
PAUL: Agreement.
Over a hundred-year period.
BRENDAN: Yeah, yeah.
PAUL: It's pretty amazing.
BRENDAN: That's actually
pretty good.
And that's exactly what that
research paper found, was that
actually in many places there
was really good coherence.
And in some places you just had
a ton of noise and it's
hard to know without
actually--
obviously, none of the ship
captains are still around.
It's hard to know exactly
what was going on.
It'd be interesting to look
and see if they ended up
waiting some more than others.
But you can see, like here off
the coast of South America,
you can see actually the
prevailing winds, say,
extremely consistent even across
the summer months and
into the winter.
You can see.
They all kind of point
towards land.
PAUL: Can you actually
see, for example,
how the routes changed?
For different years, so for
example as it got colder in
the South, was there more
activity in the North?
BRENDAN: Oh, that's actually
an interesting question.
I actually don't know.
Well, it'd be interesting how
much were they able to care
about that and how much were
they required to--
PAUL: Just bear with it.
BRENDAN: Sail anyway.
Because it was like 1750.
PAUL: We did see some kind of
Arctic and Antarctic voyages.
BRENDAN: Yeah, at certain
times of year.
They went down there, and then
it would also be interesting.
I haven't really looked yet
at summer versus winter.
Because I'm not a climatologist
nor an
oceanographer.
So, I'm still learning about
climate patterns as well.
But you can see up here
in Europe things are
still rather confused.
And I'll be very interested.
There's a couple
of techniques.
In that paper, where they talk
about ways of interpolating
between these points to
find not an average.
Because if you average out this
noise, you're just going
to get gray.
That's pretty much
the equivalent--
I don't know what you--
PAUL: Averages to zero.
BRENDAN: Yeah, pretty much.
Yeah.
And so that's not an
interesting number.
So you want to see actually
what other prevailing wind
patterns and things like that.
So, yes, this is just a start,
but this took us maybe half a
day to throw it together.
And so, this is using
CanvasLayer, which we talked
about before.
And it's up on the Maps
API Utility Library.
if you Google for that.
If you know where that is.
And it's available today.
Not this example, but that's
available today.
And there's a couple examples
included with
it to get you started.
And you can start
to take a look.
PAUL: Yeah, so we definitely
intend to share these
visualizations at some point.
We, like we mentioned, we put
them together in about a
week's time, so it's not always
the prettiest code.
But once we clean them up and
make sure that everything's in
a reasonable shape, we
definitely plan to
put these out there.
If you have any questions about
it, about what we showed
you today, definitely comments
in the YouTube stream, and
we'll get back to you there.
And one other point is we only
got to about half of the
visualizations we wanted to
today, so we might do another
follow-up in another
week or two.
Maybe once we've added some
more visualizations.
So if you're curious about that,
if you think it's a good
idea, let us know
in the comments.
If you don't think it's a good
idea, also let us know,
because we can focus our
time on other things.
Oh, Brendan is showing one
more visualization.
BRENDAN: I'm teasing
a poly line.
So poly lines are just as easy
as the other things to do.
And you're left with just some
really beautiful results with
these tendrils appearing
across the world.
And you can see where
traffic was.
These are actually colored by
country of origin, so you can
see the of diversity of
different points in some
places are very much
not diverse.
They're very much frequented
by a single country.
PAUL: Yeah, pretty easy to do.
Surprisingly.
I mean you can see how it uses
the same style as some of the
other maps.
The only trick was actually
getting these poly lines.
Brendan organized the data in
terms of voyages, and then
just converting a voyage
into a poly line.
Drawing it on the map is pretty
straightforward stuff.
I mean we're talking like five
to 10 lines of code at most.
So, yeah.
Stay tuned, we have a lot
more coming on these
visualizations.
And we hope to share more
in a week or two.
You're not going to share?
We're done with that.
So, tune in later.
And will follow up with more.
Any questions, let us know.
And we're happy to follow.
So, thanks for joining and catch
you in another week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]